That life saving technology is real, and it works
because of two main electrical principles:
Electric potential, energy, and capacitance.
[Laughter]
Okay.
[Introduction music]
[Drums]
Now, remember how you add up all the resistances
to find an equivalent resistance
for resistances in the series, Oh my god.
[Laughter]
Between the spot right next to the point charge--
[Strange noise]
[Laughter]
What was that?
That was weird.
And we did it with the help of Coulomb's law,
the equation that tells us that the force generated
by two charged particles on one another...
We call these materials s---
What *bleep* is wrong with me, okay.
We call these materials superconductors, trust me,
when I say the research into these materials
is a very important and lucrative field of study.
[Exhales breath]
We've used our hypothetical...
hypothoughticals (laughing)...new word.
Since we have two particles that eat generate...
each each generate...
Since we have two particles that each generate
their own electric fields.
Since we have two particles that each generate ...
Since we (sigh) si- (laugh) yeah, no
(from offscreen: This is very serious)
- it is, it's scary.
And since the voltage for each resistor in this is, is,
and since the voltage for each resistor
is the same in parallel you can count Saul
and since the voltage for each resistor.
And since the voltage for each resistor
is the same in parallel, you can cancel out...
(ah) and since the voltage is (ahuh).
(from offscreen: And we're done.)
A charged object can have electric potential energy when it's held in a electric field,
in an electric...in an election...
in an electric field...
This means if we place a (laughing)
you're like (points)
all I just see is K (laughing)
for our defibrillator, this energy
is quickly turned potential energy
(deep breath) I'm just breathing,
We also learned about Ohm's Law
and the relationship between voltage current
and redi... resistance.   *bleep*
[Laughing]
It just is bringing back but I anxiety
of like, loving physics and then
getting to electricity and going ugh.
This is what's gonna fail me.
Casey, you'd have loads of lines
coming out of a dot basically.
(offscreen: you've gotten further than I have) (laughs)
So one way to express capacitance
is to divide the area of each, oh my god (laughs)
So one way (laugh) I'm scared, I'm actually
scared right now. (deep breath, sigh)
Can electric field exist in a conductor where electrons
can move around freely in the material?
That's a very long question.
That's why I'm struggling.
You learn though just know
when they do, they reach
electro static equilibrium (noise)
when they do, they've reached
electro static equilibrium. (ahh) *beep*
right at the end (off camera: oh man,
that's a, ok, you can do it)
When they do, they've reached electrostatic equilibrium
(off camera: not quite) *beep*
Let's say we have a 9-volt battery
and we want to know how much current
it supplies to a light bulb.
When we...complete the circuit.
Always, I'm amazed I never really
breathe during the shoot.
Anyway, (off camera: you should do that)
yeah i might.  Might consider it
(off camera: that sounds familure, we just did a lot of that) yes, yeah yeah we just did that
(off camera #2: ok, alright,cool)
go back to bed (laughing)
Once the system is at electropshyctriatic... equilibrium
those observations we made before still hold true.
But when using a  pes...pecasitor.
yeah yeah capacitor...yeah men. (singing)
Next,  once we can generate the next cu...rrent
Next once we can generate an electric current... hello
This value is known as capatitu... capacitance.
compared to the ideal battery
it's only a one mili..m...ampure
I've just bitten my lip twice doing that saying that,
and a positively charged particle with charge positive.
Is this that Van de Graaff machine experiment I wonder.
(off camera: We're almost done we're two shots
from the end) okay who cares (laughing)
We use Ohm's Law to go from an equivalent circuit
to solving every current value
and voltage drop in the system.
Today we saw (laughing)
I broke him. (laughing)
(laughing) I broke him. oh god, sorry.
(off camera: did you see what she did?)  no
(off camera: oh god, she just, you stopped and she went (laughing) come at me script
sorry, ahh.  (laughing)